e la tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa dj e oggi siamo in
un nuovo episodio di cazzeggio time mi
sembra che debba partire una sigla della
madonna invece è proprio un cazzo in
questo caso time deciso di fare una cosa
un po strana ai miei genitori quando ero
piccolo mi avevano fatto un casino di
video non so perché erano sempre una
videocamera in mano a riprendermi così
sono rimasti una vagonata di filmati e
adesso li proverò a fare una video
reaction sono dovuta andare a prendere
questi video tipo in cantina sepolti o
eccolo così sono due miliardi di cod
questo era mio zio un tema che in realtà
mio zio si chiama tony e c'è un motivo
se ho chiamato toni cioè l'uomo purché
ragazzi ci sono un miliardo di miei
video paura di cosa sto per andare a
vedere o mio dio
minchia che sforzo enorme
mi sono ha picchiato da solo papà era
talmente piccolo che potevo starci nello
zaino anche volendo cioè io avrei fatto
sta roba solo prevedere su ma perché è
lo so ma perché anche la piccoli bisogna
avere due palle così mia nonna questa o
mio dio com'era giovane mio nonno ti com
ecco da piccolo ero l'unica l'unica
volta in cui facevo conoscenza anche con
le pietre però poi son diventato timido
col tempo ma dopo cosa tocchi cosa
tocchi durino poi guarda che mi palpa
erano dei figli che tenta di far
amicizia ma non lo sto pagando di
striscia
neanche lo cacao del free che cosa
palpito togli la mangiano uomo crollo
più socievole di adesso molto peso c'era
la smetti di palparmi la spalla le mie
doti da ezio auditore anche da piccolo
che sta roba che sta aprendo nella mia
tipo scatola di rito stava ammazzando
ammazzo chiunque me l'abbia toccata
perché mio dio ma ricordo me se fosse a
cipro spiegarmi non so come ho fatto
sviluppare questo senso della musica
anche a questa età incredibili barra che
erano i tempi nei provini degli acdc e
quindi stavo provando a fare un po di il
training ma che roba che roma che sa un
gene ragazzi era mai ma cosa che razza
di pantaloni mi metteva mia madre e mio
dio
no no non farlo no no cosa fai
no basta a questo link mettilo giu
dio mio che leggo
e stamane a nome di cota vicino
[Musica]
sono traumatizzato no no ah ah cazzo ma
mamma cosa fai
che roba non mi picchiare il culetto non
è chi ci avrebbe creduto vero papà
il muratore grazie alla fiducia papa
questo il mio preferito non è che ballo
sulla canzone di happy days senza un
apparente motivo
ecco grande denunciamo mal di testa
tutto queste cose ecco infatti la spider
man oh mio dio a quello questo ok questa
roba non deve andare su internet due
però non ancora il periodo dei
videogiochi però io è saltato il tasto
hicks prima non era così quanto niente
intimato a fa sta roba cioè fatemi
capire roba telecamera gli ultimissimi
minuti sia camera ci abbiamo provato dai
sembrargli vedere incontro di breslin
tra rey mysterio è di ciò cosa fanno oh
mio dio
sanremo
sanremo sanremo cos'è la mia in aula
quella associata nonché una fila lorenzo
bravo mi sento un autore artistico che
poi aprì a non aquila hashtag a perché
quelle sono forme fa le nicchie che da
piccolo costruivo non regge troppo
incassato dai team o la stessa reaction
gioco quando bar nei videogiochi
l'architetto o far da grande ho
sbagliato il mio fatto che arriva tra
l'altro la ride perché piano liga ride
non capisci un cavolo di ragazzi io ero
malato di happy days e quel giorno mi
hanno tolto ep days dalla televisione
nel senso che non hanno più trasmessa
che la mia reaction è stata
[Musica]
a favore bambino le avete tolto il pi
day sono un bambino distrutto dalla vita
perché mi adesso a costruire mi hanno
tolto pure fidei se quindi la vita è una
merda al mare così raccolto un'alga sono
perché è bellissimo il pelo di mare e lo
di mare e al gas chiamasi alga tesoro
amministravano le torce in faccia grazie
stato ceco a 10 anni vediamo
speriamo va ecco io continuerò a vita a
fare così pare che continua a fare così
anche se non c'è più la luce bellissima
e qui ero con mia nonna che dolce vorrei
che sta col nostro nonno ami i segni
d'amore volevo darle il bacio quindi che
tiravo il naso bellissimo sono proprio
andate fra questo e fridzon nonna zone o
che almeno la scena di gameplay abbiamo
sempre in ritardo nel proprio integro ma
ora che si abbassa proprio mentre tentò
di quel piglio del tristissimo guarda
quella che riguarda divertitissimo
perché non ce la facciano a colpirne uno
piazza l
è bellissima non ce la faccia col dm v1
in croce ma meglio chi triste o no mica
uno stato assurdo
niente ci abbiamo provato a quanti sono
spaventato a morte a guardarlo
in calabria mio sguardo è bellissimo
[Musica]
e da quei ragazzi si capisce che gli
horror mi fanno un certo effetto ma si
vede il mio nerdismo a tre anni cometa
il via tra cui sociali della metal gear
tre anni impossibile
ora che si è alzato in piedi ragazzi la
sfida è cominciata la concentrazione
tutto è perché deve finire su youtube
caro mio
ma perché io avevo capito tutto ma è
così che si conquista le donne finendo i
videogiochi la patata arrivato ai
quattro ragazzi che possono includere
qui è stata una full immersion dei tempi
andati c'è una roba pazzesca quindi
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto è
stato è stato bello riguardare un po il
video vecchie di tanto guardo foto
queste del genere da solo quindi fare
una reaction sembrava una cosa carina e
niente ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
questo cazzeggio time non mi piace per
il mio cappellino swag a livelli
paranormali se il video è piaciuto come
al solito lasciato argomento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come non
divido tratta descrizione se non sempre
si ti schianti ci vediamo al prossimo
minuti e da ragazzi